We want to get the latest from
Dr. Tom Engels be director
of the Center for Health
Security at Johns Hopkins
University doctor I want
to start with some more numbers
put him up on the screen more
than 83,000 people are now
hospitalized in this country.
That's a record high over 16,000
are in ICUs and more than 5,000
are on ventilators why are we
seeing this new spike right now
and how close are we
to overwhelming our health care
system.
Well good morning Chris.
Thanks for having me
on your show we are seeing this
new spike because of the gradual
accumulation of choices
and policies over the last
couple of months this virus has
the ability to spread
exponentially meaning more
and more rapidly if we let it.
And unlike the springtime when
the country really was acting
kind of with common purpose
around March and April
at the start of this pandemic
and where the virus was located
in comparatively fewer Cape
places the epidemic now is
surging in almost every state
in the country with the Midwest
and the Mountain West really
being out really in front
in terms of rapidly accelerating
numbers of cases.
So it's not it's not confined
to a few places it's really
spread across the country.
It's not just in big cities
but it's in rural locations
small towns and so that is
adding up to record numbers
of hospitalizations.
And as you said the pressure
on hospitals is the highest
it's been since the beginning
of the pandemic with about 1,000
hospitals reporting this week
that they are critically short
on health care workers or will
be very soon and that number
will grow this week.
So it's a very very serious
moment for the country in terms
of this pandemic at least 37
states are now requiring people
to wear masks in public
but the debate over masks
and partial or total closures
shutdowns is continuing here is
South Dakota Governor Christie
no I'm not in favor of mandating
mask wearing I don't believe
that I have the authority
to mandate that and that people
can use their own personal
responsibility to make
a decision when it comes
to masks what about the argument
that government can recommend
but it shouldn't be ordering
people what to do or not to do
well we trust government to do
things to keep us safe.
So we trust government to set
speed limits in neighborhoods
so we don't drive too fast
and risk injuring or killing
kids or playing in the street
and a neighborhood so I think
that would be the analogy I
would think of here.
I think there are some times
when it's really important
for government to set the rules
and to ask people to follow
them.
And I think this is one of those
times if 37 states can set mask
mandates then the rest
of the states can set mask
mandates as well and they should
let me ask you about another
aspect of this particular debate
New York City just shut down its
public schools school system
forcing more than one million
students to stay at home.
But there is some growing
evidence that in fact schools
are not major spreaders
of the disease here is CDC
director Dr. Robert Redfield
this week the truth is for kids
K through 12 one of the safest
place they can be from
our perspective is to remain
in school doctor
what's the science are kids
safer staying in school so it
does look like at the K through
level of school that kids are
both at certainly at lower risk
of serious disease and probably
because of the way school
happens smaller groups of kids
not mixing together no large
assemblies that they are safer
than high schools
or universities for example we
haven't had reports of major
outbreaks
driving transmission
in communities but on the other
hand,
we are not systematically enough
collecting data around
the country right now
and the schools that have made
mitigation measures have been
able to decrease classroom
density have been able to have
kids wear masks and assemblies
change pickup and drop off those
schools we think are doing
better and are creating safer
environments but not all schools
have been able to do that not
all schools have had
the resources to put mitigation
measures in place so I do think
it's hard to have universal
rules I don't think we can go
that far but in places where
they've put mitigation
procedures in place
and community transmission
in that particular school
district is relatively low I do
think those
are safer environments
the problem is that now we are
seeing transmission levels
across the country that are
higher than they've ever been
since the start of this
pandemic.
So we are kind of entering
in uncharted territory in many
places which have enormous rates
of spread.
So we haven't seen those rates
of spread in other parts
of the world.
So we don't really have those
places to learn from.
And I think we have to be very
cautious about about making
judgments about safety
in schools when the rate gets
so high in communities and then
there is Thanksgiving we are
seeing already airports with
long lines of people waiting
on line going through security
getting on planes should people
travel for Thanksgiving or not
and if they're bound to anyway
what can they do to minimize
their risk.
So I would recommend that people
do not travel on Thanksgiving
for this particular holiday I
think if you look at the map
of spread across the country.
You can see the risk is very
visible and moving through
airports or travel hubs I think
that will increase
people's risk.
But even if they're driving from
point to point unfortunately we
don't know if we're infected
when we walk into a gathering
CDC came out with data.
This week that said that more
than 50% of infections that are
happening are caused by people
with no symptoms.
So I think the message
for everyone is you can't assume
that you don't have the virus
and you can't assume that
the people whose home
you're about to enter don't have
the virus at this point
in our pandemic.
And so we really should
discourage traveling and kind
of stick with our nuclear
families the people that we live
with if you are going to travel
to someone else's home
for Thanksgiving then
if possible you should spend
as much time outdoors when
you're together in some places
that may be possible with
the weather other places not
people should be wearing masks
indoors when they're together
and only removing them when
they're eating.
We should probably keep meals
short and spend more time with
masks on.
And the smaller the gatherings
the better but in general,
I would recommend against it I
love being with my family
on Thanksgiving but this year
we're staying home just
our nuclear family but Dr. Scott
Atlas who is one of President
Trump's top COVID 19 officials
gave very different advice this
week.
Take a look this kind
of isolation is one
of the unspoken tragedies
of the elderly who are now being
told don't see your family
at Thanksgiving for many people,
this is their final Thanksgiving
believe it or not what are we
doing here straight out should
people listen to Doctor outlets
or not you know I don't think
so.
I think there there are a number
of officials from the US
government who have 30 years
of experience preparing
for and responding to infectious
disease outbreaks including Dr.
Phil g and I think their advice
has been very clear CDC is
advice is very clear CDC whose
job is to try to prevent
the spread of outbreaks.
I think I don't know Dr. Atlas
but his background is quite
different.
And I think we should stick with
the scientists who've led us
through past outbreaks I've got
two questions I want to squeeze
in here so I'm going to need
quick answers from you first
of all, there is some good news
and that of course, is the fact
that looks like that we have not
one but two vaccines as part
of Operation Warp Speed that are
on the way Pfizer on Friday
applied for emergency use
authorization assuming that
they're approved by the FDA how
confident should Americans be
about taking these vaccines.
Yeah I wouldn't call
there's good news I would call
this great news it's fantastic
it's part of the best news
we've had since the start
of the pandemic, we have two
vaccines that are making
their way through the approval
process that may be as high
as 95% effective and seem to be
safe based on the information
we've seen so far obviously they
need to go through the usual FDA
review process and that's going
to begin now for one
of the vaccines and we'll begin
shortly for the second.
But if it does get through that
process and if they are reviewed
by an external scientific
committee which has no stake
in the outcome except
for the safety and effectiveness
for Americans of these vaccines
then I will have confidence
in those vaccines of course I
want to know about others from
within the government what they
think about it what Dr. fouled
things about it what other
scientific authorities and FDA
and CDC think about it.
But at this point I will have
confidence in the vaccine
and if if it makes it through
those processes and I think it
will help us change the course
of this pandemic in the months
ahead finally and I need a quick
answer here that delayed
your transition President-elect
Biden said today that people may
because the Trump administration
does not reading the man
on vaccine distribution issues
for a seamless turnover
on January 20
but the president's press
secretary kayleigh McEnany said
that information is already out
there take a look.
We don't have access to all
the information that we need
to get from all the various
agencies if we covered 92
vaccination program the interim
playbook for jurisdiction
operations this is publicly
available if the former vice
president would like to read
through it is McCain any right
is the public playbook enough no
it's not I mean there's so much
going on inside the government
to prepare to respond to this
pandemic and to prepare for it I
think about it like a hospital,
taking care of many patients
when a shift is leaving
the doctors and nurses
who've been taking care of all
these sick patients they spend
time with the shift that is
coming in they to explain
the details what could go wrong
who's been in trouble
that's the same thing that
should be happening now we
should be going over the details
the people who are leaving are
going to need to take need
to spend time with and explain
in detail all the science
and the data for people who are
coming in Dr. angles thank you
Thanks again for your time.
And we wish you a happy and safe
Thanksgiving sir Thanks so much,
Chris you too.